taiwan's highest civilian honor awarded
to its high-profile guest of honor
top u.s politician nancy pelosi proudly
displayed her new medal on this brief
but brazen visit
she's here in defiance of chinese
warnings and even the advice of her own
president
today the world faces a choice between
democracy
and autocracy
america's determination to preserve
democracy here in taiwan and around the
world
remains ironclad
the gratitude all too clear from the
leader of this self-governed island
which china views as a breakaway region
that it wants to control by force if
necessary
thank you for taking concrete actions to
show your staunch support for taiwan at
this critical moment and for expressing
the us's consistent policy supporting
taiwan's self-defense
as the third most powerful politician in
washington visited various sites she'd
have been all too aware the issue of
taiwan is the most sensitive in u.s
china relations
washington agrees to have formal
diplomatic ties only with beijing and to
keep its contact with taipei more
unofficial under a long-standing policy
of one china
it's why the site of the touring u.s
house speaker has sparked such fury
the us is infringing on china's
sovereignty
in response to pelosi's visit the
chinese military is conducting its
largest drills aimed at taiwan in more
than 25 years they're expected to take
place within these six boxed off areas
encircling the island the main live
firing exercises from the air and the
sea are due to last from thursday
through to sunday now neither side say
they want a war but an accidental
exchange could ignite just that
the g7 group of nations have voiced
concern and say china's moves risk
increasing tensions and destabilizing
the region
taiwan's defense ministry posted this
video to make clear it's ready to fight
if necessary any move either side makes
is now viewed through the prism of the
very real war in ukraine with china and
taiwan both drawing lessons from
russia's invasion
pelosi clearly believes her flying visit
will bolster taiwan
rather than backfire
debra haynes sky news